[Applause]
it's week three of the masked singer and
another mass celeb has flown the coop
we're gonna get into all of it plus
we're gonna be running down the three
new singing celebs we met tonight hi
guys I'm Deidre Behar and I'm Charlie
O'Keeffe like you said tonight the
eagle's wings were sadly clipped but
let's soar into that latest elimination
one more time
dr. Drew Pinsky and dr. on the master
well now we have two doctors on the
masked singer initial thoughts reactions
not who I expected total I definitely
want to pin a doctor to join a singing
competition show hey live your best life
your best life but he wasn't bad no he
wasn't bad at all listen if you're a dr.
Drew fan you know this guy has actually
given singing a bit of a stab in the
past he performed the national anthem in
2016 at an NHL game really impressive I
think it's cool that just because you're
a doctor doesn't necessarily exclude you
from pursuing other passions your life
you know I don't think he's looking for
a record deal but like the guy had fun
and I respect that I respect it you want
to say one more time and he took it to
the mass singer and he had a good time
up there and I totally listen here's
what dr. Drew had to say about wanting
to pursue his singing career take a look
I for five minutes thought I was gonna
be a singer and thank God I turned back
from that because I'm a terrible
musician my son who's a great second a
great musician coached me into that I
mean I think that's awesome and it's a
really positive message it's so in line
with what the masked singer stands for
live your best life pursue your passions
do whatever is fun for you did you think
it was dr. drew when you were watching
the clues not exactly I almost thought
teacher at one point or someone who'd
played a teacher in a movie or film
could be a sergeants a tank totally but
I wouldn't have gone doctor no I listen
I was thinking Bret Michaels okay so red
bandana talked about a health scare
which we know Bret unfortunately went
through but listen dr. drew we salute
you and we want more singing from you
and over on Twitter a lot of you had
your own yeses but this is my
particularly favorite one Adam Carolla
who is dr. Drew's longtime co-host on
Loveline he said I can't quite put my
finger on the Eagles voice but it
certainly sounds familiar and II Albert
Vanson tweeted guarantee this eagle on
the mast singer is Will Ferrell as Ron
Burgundy stay classy stay classy so the
Eagle may be gone but you know we're
just getting started ruffling feathers
let's pick apart the petals on the
flower
[Music]
I'm stumped listen I can smell the pie
it is Miss Patti LaBelle interesting
okay what makes you say that
all of those clues were pointing I mean
the baking in the kitchen pie by Patti
the iconic sweet potato pie that sells
out every year yeah Patti LaBelle
actually received an honorary degree
from Temple University we saw that
hanging on the wall did anything point
towards her for you well so listen I'll
be honest the first thing I heard in the
clue package was the term rosebuds then
I saw the Temple University things so
rosebuds that's the name of the fan base
for amber Rose's fans and I know she's
from Philadelphia where Temple is
located so initially I was thinking
could this be Amber Rose then I started
listening a little more intently and and
the clue package said I'm a woman who's
dabbled in everything from cooking to
clothing to crafts and if we take a look
at Patti LaBelle's career she's actually
had a cooking show on the cooking
network called Patti LaBelle's place she
also had a clothing line with HSN so
then that's working in the in the Patti
LaBelle area
[Music]
[Applause]
I think she goes out and sings and I
mean that that is a one-in-a-billion
voice voice is so recognizable you can't
recognize about 100%
[Applause]
[Music]
and actually in 2015 Patti LaBelle made
a guest appearance on Empire on Fox a
lot of people were thinking taraji yeah
but how do you still make sense here
100% I think this one is still really
tough I don't know if I'm a hundred
percent sold it's just these are all
things that I think work and Patti
LaBelle's favor you guys over on Twitter
at angel tweeted it's illegal to not
think that flower is Patti LaBelle so
she agrees with us
totally and Manny p85 tweeted dude the
flower is Tina Turner which I'm not sold
on I would love me some Tina Turner in
the show I just don't think but I'll
take Patti oh my god I mean we worship
Patti Miss Patti up next let's chill
with the penguin Wow what do you think
I'm stumped and I think this show is
actually starting to stop us correct
I mean they're getting so much more
creative and mysterious with the clues
that they're choosing to divulge all
right my best guest for this one is
Sherri Shepherd okay so we saw in the
clue package there was a nod to a comedy
club obviously no Sherri does stand-up
comedy she also said I don't need a
permission slip Sherri has put out a
book called permission slips every
woman's guide to giving herself a break
she wants her voice to be heard we know
Sherri was on the view she's very
opinionated and outspoken what do you
think they actually guessed Sherri last
year which I thought was funny because
now it's coming back again my good
friend Sybil well she said in this day
and age I need a show that just makes me
laugh and feel good that's right that's
what the mask say you're done hundred
percent we've got those like celebrities
journeys and all that I know can't
believe it you were a [ __ ] oh you guys
so most you know maybe she actually is
on the show this time she was available
it's her and that's the personality I
mean the penguin was having fun up there
dancing around we saw even in the battle
round having a good time so I'm kind of
sold with Sherri as well yeah I got to
tell you I am I am still sort of on the
fence about it because a big part of the
clue package was this person thought
their career was over that breaks my
heart this is obviously someone who's
been through a lot and it has had an
emotional ride through their career or
their life my brain went to two people
Rose McGowan and Kathy Griffin obviously
Kathy the comedy
action but both of them rose and Kathy
they've dealt with controversies very
public controversies that I'm sure
really affected them internally so I am
curious if they want a fresh start a
restart go on the masked singer and kind
of just you know start over a little bit
what do you think I could see that I
think the protest signs that we saw in
the package and the piece that kind of
gave me some more of those Rose McGowan
vibes is totally but I think I'm going
sherry stone yeah I think I'm gonna
stick with sherry what do you guys think
while we know ATL marina tweeted I think
it's Tonya Harding stuff interesting
right
she's mad small and I'm thinking that
penguin is a slight nod to her ice
skating career okay I can see that the
nice definitely play into it
yeah and I'm Connolly 20 tweeted oh my
god penguin just killed it this is
officially Sherri Shepherd yeah I'm with
M Connolly I'm with Stanley as well well
lastly we want to know what does the
[ __ ] sing Wayne Wayne Wayne Wayne Wayne
Wayne Wayne
[Music]
No
[Music]
Charlie I need to issue a retraction
I want to issue a formal retraction we
sat here during episode 1 of this
after-show and we both were super sold
on the fact that the thingamajig was
Wayne Brady this has got to be Wayne
Brady completely do you think it's Wayne
Brady I think it's Wayne Brady I've seen
him on Broadway actually in kinky boots
when he was in that about two years ago
and I can recognize that voice 100% and
then also the outfit that the
thingamajig is wearing it looks like
Wayne Brady hand designed that himself
then fast forward to tonight
we watched the Fox perform I now think
the Fox is Wayne Brady we want Wayne
Brady on this show does Wayne Brady's
stand exactly so here's here's my
biggest reason why I think it's Wayne
Brady
number one the voice the performance
quality this is someone who knows how to
navigate a stage who commands the
audience with like such a big presence
but also take a look at the costume look
in the eye it's a very superhero looking
Fox not your like cute cuddly rocks
Wayne as diverse as his career has been
he's never done anything quote superhero
traditionally at least and now he's set
to play grave digger on CW's Black
Lightning and I pulled this quote that
he recently said quote anyone who knows
me knows that me being in a sci-fi or
superhero project that's where my heart
is so if he's got a new show that he's
promoting it would totally make sense
that he's on the masked singer and it's
kind of like a cool way to parallel both
projects with one another and I don't
think that was just a celebrity in there
that was a performer I mean we saw them
go to the edge of the stage and start
dancing I think more judges were
surprised as well they were putting on a
concert production there it was not just
another singer correct and look I know
we we spoke on episode one about how
Wayne such a seasoned Broadway performer
you saw him take a look at the bow at
the end of that performance a star who
has not done Broadway wouldn't probably
know how to take a very foreign robber
but a regal bow exactly so I I think
between the voice the superhero thing
and and the way that he commanded that
stage that's got to be weighing brave at
least we're hoping well yeah fingers
crossed for Wayne Brady I positively
lissa tweeted the Foxx is Wayne Brady
it has to be I feel it in my bones so
listen agrees with us I agree and Crum
Tyranno tweeted watching masked singer
and the Fox is so obviously jeremy
renner it's not even funny
I mean I love Jeremy Renner I so we've
said goodbye to Johnny we're ninja Laila
Ali and now dr. drew but things on the
mess singer are just heating up there is
still plenty of guessing to do on next
week's episode when we dive even deeper
into clue packages and performances and
of course post a comment below with your
vest and craziest theories and tweet us
so we can all guess together you never
know it might end up on the show yes I'm
at Charles E O'Keefe and I'm at Deidre
Behar we'll see you next week